losing my vision taught me to be more
fearless in life if you can't see how
steep the mountain is then you can't
fear it if my mom were still here today
I would ask her to teach me how to make
her Vietnamese beef noodle soup
Alexa asked Delta to turn on she was
able to take very simple ingredients and
do something magical to them since she
dies she left no written recipes Alexa
asked Delta to dispense four quarts of
water so I have yet to figure out how to
make her miss tea rias beef noodle soup
because I'm visually impaired I'm known
as the blind cook and I just opened my
first restaurant called the blind goat I
started losing my vision around the same
time that I started teaching myself how
to cook every time my vision would
decrease I would have to teach myself
again how do I use the stove or how do I
use a knife just trying to get better
every day with every recipe I made I'm
best known for winning a cooking
competition on television I also wrote a
cookbook that made it onto the
bestseller list
now I'm considered an insider in the
industry as someone who's visually
impaired measuring liquids has been a
challenge I use voice-activated
technology a lot in the kitchen it's
just much easier to speak to a device
whether it's measurements getting
equipment to turn on or off cooking is a
very sensual process because I don't
have the sense of sight when I taste
something I really break it down in my
head
I picture exactly how I want the dish to
look I have the memory of what colors
look like so I know what white what
orange what green look like so I imagine
first I think the art on a dish
this is when I feel the most sin is a
dish that even though it's that simple
it's hard to execute although each time
I make it it gets better and better it
has yet to still capture the memory of
my mom's whether it's trying to get
through challenges to win a cooking
competition to opening a restaurant to
just trying to replicate my mom's beef
noodle soup you just have to try over
and over until you succeed comfort food
at the end of the day is what matters to
me most but it's really something that
reminds you of childhood that brings
back certain memories that makes you
feel sentimental for the past I would
not trade where I am today to have my
vision back when I cook I feel like my
mom's spirit is somewhere nearby
I think all of these things are a
tribute to her and in homage to how my
mom viewed food
you
[Music]
you